foreign
I loved science because it wasn't
political and politics right and now
we're getting rid of that everybody kind
of gets in line they start checking the
Box they don't want to rock the boat
they don't want to self-sabotage and
nobody really thinks about the broader
impacts of all this stuff or possibly
what this is doing to students and our
culture in general
I think on the University campus there's
essentially like three forbidden fruit
right now and I happen to unluckily pick
two of them Dei climate and gender are
essentially these three things that are
Untouchable if you start to discuss
these things you know the goal of earth
science is to make sure that the public
has a a well-rounded view of the state
of the planet and how to face the
challenges that we will face you know
environmentally in the future and I
started asking my students and polling
my students and I realized they had an
exactly upside down view of the state of
the climate I would ask them you know
whether or not in the last hundred years
have them been significantly more about
the same or significantly less people
that die from natural disasters on a
yearly or decade basis and the vast
majority would say significantly more
but in fact we've lowered you know
fatalities from natural disaster
something like 98 over the last hundred
years and so
more and more of my students would talk
to me and tell me about their feelings
about climate I was shocked that many of
my students told me that although they
were planning on having a family they no
longer wanted to do that they would feel
guilty by starting a family because they
really were convinced that the planet
was going to come into some I don't know
catastrophe in 8 or 10 or 12 years and
it wasn't worth it to try to raise a
family we were robbing these young
people of their ambition of their hope
you know why would they sacrifice now if
and and work for a brighter future if
they didn't think they had a future and
I felt like as an earth scientist that's
like my community that isn't speaking up
and and is letting you know false
narratives get out there by things like
the ipcc the the world economic Forum
the UN that are constantly telling us
that the you know Al Gore up there
saying the oceans will boil
there's no chance that the oceans will
boil they've never boiled before they'll
never boil in the future these are
absolutely ridiculous claims by adults
that know better that that take at what
they're called they don't consider they
act you know the words that they speak
and the mental health effects that
they're having on young people and then
we wonder why young people have no
ambition and they don't really think
about their future and it's just all of
these things are interconnected I never
blame the young people I know Greta out
is out there she probably really
believes that she's helping to save the
planet I really believe that I blame the
adults that are experts in the field
that either sit on you know and zip
their mouth because they don't want to
rock the boat and you know you'll hear
in the back channels I know that's not
really true what they're saying but this
brings us more funding this brings us
more you know exposure so let's just not
say anything I think that scientific
Integrity is more important than getting
a little bit of extra dollars or trying
to motivate people to change their
behavior year by giving them bad data
there's going to be bigger challenges in
the future and then people like me that
are scientists or nobody's going to
listen to us we saw it with covid we're
seeing it with climate we keep making
the same mistakes give the people all
the information let them figure it out
you know don't try to swayed people into
behavioral changes by claiming science
is doing this because you're omitting
one part you're only giving one side of
the story and then you're
catastrophizing or over exaggerating
that side to try to make a point because
they claim the ends justify the means if
I disagree with that I think scientific
Integrity is way more important than
that and to me being in the community I
just you know those two reasons together
it made it a lot easier to walk away and
probably
commit career suicide I doubt a
university will pick me up but you know
with by now being a father I just saw is
more important the the career started to
lose its appeal to me because of this
stuff these these negative consequences
that are worse that I was seeing started
to really be you know I noticed them
much more I started to see all the
negative impacts young people should
have hope for their future
um there is going to be challenges
there's always going to be if we're
always going to face challenges but they
have a bright future and they should be
thinking about sacrifices they make now
to ensure that that future is brighter
instead of just kind of losing all
ambition and hope because that's the
worst way to motivate someone to be a
good Steward of the environment is if
they're not hopeful for a future that
has a good environment